antes de entrar en lo sustancial del
álgebra quiero citar una frase de una de
las mentes más brillantes de toda la
historia de la humanidad
galileo galilei y la frase dice
la filosofía está escrita en ese
grandísimo libro abierto ante nuestros
ojos quiero decir el universo pero no se
puede entender si antes no aprendemos su
lenguaje y distinguimos los símbolos en
el que está escrito este libro está
escrito en el lenguaje de las
matemáticas sin las cuales uno deambula
vanamente en un oscuro laberinto es una
frase muy dramática y muy profunda y ese
es el punto de las matemáticas veremos
como ahora que empecemos a adentrarnos
en el álgebra y a medida que vayamos
profundizando en las matemáticas y nos
permitirán aplicarlas a ciencias como la
economía la física la química pero en su
esencia son ellas mismas y son más puras
y profundas que sus aplicaciones
pero para observar a lo que me estoy
refiriendo para ir a la raíz de esta
idea
ahora vayamos a algo muy concreto algo
muy simple el ejemplo que voy a plantear
pues es muy simple imaginemos que
estamos en una tienda y que hay una
oferta pero en esta oferta nos están
ofreciendo que hay un descuento del 30%
y digamos que voy a comprar unos
pantalones bueno yo normalmente no voy a
tiendas muy sofisticadas y que antes de
la oferta los pantalones que estoy
buscando cuestan 20 pesos pues
normalmente es más o menos de este los
que yo compro así que estoy interesado
en unos pantalones de 20 pesos y además
hay una oferta de 30 por ciento de
descuento sobre el precio de estos
pantalones y también me hace pensar en
cuanto a pagar menos en la compra de
estos pantalones pero este es un
problema de álgebra
y así puedes decir que tu descuento es y
lo vamos a escribir así es el 30%
multiplicado por los 20 pesos los 20
vamos a escribirlo en morado y también
podríamos expresarlo de manera decimal o
sea decir que esto es punto 30 x los 20
pesos y bueno se hace las
multiplicaciones esto nos da 6
nada demasiado especial en este caso
pero qué pasa si yo quisiera generalizar
lo es decir no solo el descuento en este
par de pantalones sino en cualquier
producto de la tienda
así que lo voy a escribir aquí y podría
yo decir en sea x el precio que voy a
pagar por cualquier producto antes del
descuento sin descuento del producto en
la tienda
y entonces vamos a decir que el
descuento
es igual a 30% veces x xi 30% veces x o
si lo queremos escribir como decimal
pues será igual a 0.30 veces x y esto se
pone interesante porque ahora me puedes
dar el precio de cualquier producto en
la tienda yo lo sustituyó por x lo
multiplicó por punto 30 y obtengo el
descuento y empezamos a adentrarnos poco
a poco al pensamiento abstracto al de la
algebra e iremos matizando y
profundizando en conceptos más bellos y
más sofisticados a medida que estudiemos
ideas algebraicas y por lo pronto ya
acabamos con este ejemplo decimos una
generalización y ya encontramos una
relación que por ejemplo si yo tomar un
producto de 10 pesos pues el descuento
sería punto 3 por 10 que es 3 de la
misma manera que para uno de 100 pesos
pues el descuento será 30 pero vamos a
generalizar esto aún
y ahora vamos a pensar en esto cuál
sería el precio para cualquier descuento
y veamos cuál va a ser el descuento esto
lo vamos a definir una variable voy a
decir sea m
no mejor sea p
sea p el porcentaje el porcentaje de
descuento
y entonces diremos que el descuento el
descuento va a ser igual al porcentaje
de descuento
va a ser igual al porcentaje de
descuento veces el precio si el precio
del producto antes del descuento
o sea el descuento va a ser igual al
porcentaje de descuento veces x
y qué interesante ahora tenemos una
fórmula general que nos permite calcular
cualquier descuento para cualquier
porcentaje de oferta y cualquier precio
equis y no teníamos que usar estas
letras por ejemplo podríamos haber dicho
que sea igual al descuento
y en vez de escribirlo como descuento
podríamos decir
y será igual al porcentaje de descuento
veces el precio del producto si el
precio del producto antes del descuento
y como se puede observar bueno en vez de
g podríamos utilizar cualquier símbolo
cualquier letra griega siempre y cuando
no perdamos de vista que estamos
hablando del descuento y las cosas
siguen poniéndose muy interesantes
porque podemos utilizar este tipo de
ecuación si lo que tenemos aquí es una
ecuación tenemos aquí es a lo que le
llamamos una ecuación y podemos
utilizarla para cosas que no tienen nada
que ver ni con tiendas ni con descuentos
por ejemplo en física sabemos que la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración y estas dos cosas que están
aquí tienen diferentes letras pero es la
misma idea y podríamos decir que jesse a
la fuerza y que pese a m algo que pese a
la masa y claro esto no haría las cosas
muy intuitivas pero es la misma relación
es la misma idea es la misma relación
la misma idea que se está aplicando a
dos cosas totalmente diferentes y
podríamos seguir diciendo ahora que x
sea la aceleración y ahora la famosa
relación para la fuerza la podríamos
escribir como que f que en este caso va
a ser y va a ser igual a la masa que
estamos utilizando a pe veces la
aceleración que estamos utilizando x y
esta es exactamente la misma ecuación y
entonces podemos tomar esta ecuación y
utilizarla en la economía en las
finanzas o en las ciencias de la
computación o en la lógica o en la
ingeniería mecánica o bueno puedes ver
hay infinidad de aplicaciones de esta
ecuación y lo que es maravilloso de las
matemáticas y de la álgebra es que
podemos establecer estas relaciones y
manipularlas
y después aplicarlas a esta infinidad de
aplicaciones que aquí tenemos y algo
maravilloso también es que nos está
dando una estructura
una estructura profunda de cómo funciona
el universo y estas aplicaciones humanas
y por ejemplo si dijéramos observa que
es igual a px y otra persona dijera esta
es y la otra persona dijera este spee
keys
podríamos decir bueno los dos tienen la
misma cosa los dos tienen lo mismo y si
yo dividiera un lado bueno pues
dividiría también el del otro lado lo
dividiría por el mismo número y por
ejemplo bueno ya sabemos que es igual a
px y qué pasaría si yo quisiera saber
cuánto es de entre x
bueno pues será px dividido entre x
y aquí es importante observar que si yo
a algo lo multiplicó y lo divido entre
el mismo número pues voy a obtener el
número original por ejemplo si yo tomo p
y lo multiplicó por 5 y lo divido entre
5 pues me queda p así que en este caso
se cancelan y estamos manipulando
abstracciones y entonces tendría que
entre x a ver déjame escribirlo mejor y
entre x es igual a p
y ahora esto tiene implicaciones en
todas estas ideas lo que nos está
diciendo tiene que ver con la naturaleza
del universo y con todas estas
actividades
y planteamos modelos y regresamos y los
volvemos a aplicar en estas actividades
y el número de aplicaciones será
infinito y no las conocemos todas iremos
descubriendo lo a través de los miles de
años y con suerte esto te dará una idea
de por qué
galileo dijo lo que dijo que las
matemáticas es el lenguaje que nos
permitirá conocer la filosofía del
universo y está también la razón por la
cual ciertas gentes piensan que si
encontráramos vida extraterrestre
las matemáticas serían una base para
empezar a establecer una comunicación